oh my god want you show um what show oh
you're doing you too yeah well that's
not a show I just post videos that I
make do but what's a troll well it's not
a show because there's no like intro and
I just talked about dupid stuff and a
post random videos like as a show maybe
it's not a show I know that's what I
said it's not a show well it looks great
idea why don't you make a show uh okay
oh I'm so excited me I can push your
hair so what's your show gonna be about
mmm yeah that's the hard part maybe no
idea mm-hmm well I guess you can
basically do a show on anything trim
like creamy coffee a coffee sure the
computer select a person we go through
your show
how about it's on knitting team it
public in it you can't met Kenyon
actually can't mitt maybe on a cooking
show looking great yep mmm nope can't
cook yeah that's right you can't cook
what do you guys think I should do a
show about I mean I can always sit here
and talk to myself and deepen my voice
and they
whatever yeah like I said leave me
comments below